multi-platinum rockers Collective Soul
will be at the Pearl concert theater
tomorrow night and earlier today I spoke
with founding member will Turpin about
the band's 30-year history in what we
can expect at the show
[Music]
so people might not know this but you
guys started this whole thing started
back in high school you guys were high
school friends when you first started
the band back in early 90s did you think
you'd be still running 30 years later
no we didn't think about that man we we
do uh
enjoy some of the same uh fun things we
did back then but yeah we had no idea we
weren't we weren't thinking about a
30-year career we were thinking about
the next record or the next show uh and
and you know it worked out for us
[Music]
the song shine Smash Hit and you guys
were kind of um like a band at I mean
Glam Rock was coming to an end
alternative rock was was starting to
make its way onto the radio stations you
guys were the kind of forefathers of
alternative rock what was that like for
you
you know it was just like um
you know we were we grew up in the Glam
era like you mentioned right we grew so
we weren't necessarily the biggest fans
of that we were listening to more uh of
like a YouTube's records or rem's
records from Georgia
um in excess I remember things like that
so a lot of the bands that came out in
the 90s were a little bit tired of the
um the same the same uh you know the
same style of song and we were just we
were just writing songs about real
things that happened to us or something
we knew and it was just a little a
little bit different than singing about
partying and staying up all night you
know and girls girls girls and girls
right I mean those are great subjects I
understand
but uh yeah we were trying to do
something a little different and you
guys certainly did and it has certainly
worked for you guys do you remember
where you were the first time you heard
shine on the radio or in your car when
your house where's the first time you
heard you guys on the radio
we were actually on the way to a show in
Orlando Orlando Florida was the first
city with a commercial station as they
say to play shot so we were going down
there for a a show and we were actually
all in a rental van and uh I don't know
why we stopped but we stopped on the
side of the road to jump out and just
jump out and hug each other and I don't
know why we stopped but we stopped on
the side of the highway
hour
rounds
[Music]
we're happy you're coming to town any
any Vegas memories or Vegas stories or
shows that stand out to you over the
years oh yeah we've had some good ones
Vegas is actually a good rock and roll
crowd
um just good just good times you know uh
just good late night scenes in Vegas I
if you can remember them well then maybe
it wasn't as fun as you thought it was
anyway that's the ones I remember not
the fun ones the one that completely
blacked out those are the good ones
that's right I love it well thank you so
much we look forward to seeing this
weekend buddy Collective Soul over at
the Palms thanks man